[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihn allen an einem
Tag der erhebliche Folgen hat für die
wichtigsten Zukunftsprojekte der
Bundesregierung als da wären Umbau der
Wirtschaft Richtung Klimaschutz Ausbau
der E-Mobilität Förderung von neuen
Heizungen Modernisierung der Bahn die
Idee die die Regierung hatte um all das
zu finanzieren hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht heute für null
und nichtichtig erklärt der
Finanzminister steht jetzt wie jemand da
der einen hohen Kredit aufnehmen wollte
der nun geplatzt ist sprich ihm fehlt
sehr viel Geld genau 60 Milliarden der
Wirtschaft minister steht als jemand da
dessen Projekte für die Zukunft einen
ziemlich entscheidenden Marel haben sie
sind aktuell nicht finanziert allein
dadurch wird klar der heutige Tag wird
neu erbitterten Streit ums Geld mit sich
bringen und damit auch potentiell
gewaltige politische Folgen haben wir
beginnen mit Jura und einer Klatsche aus
Karlsruhe und
saratacke es ist noch gar nicht lange
her da kam der Kanzler mit einem v Korb
aus dem Vollen schöpfen für Grün
gelbrote
milliardenprojekte Verkehrswende
Energiewende Zeitenwende der geldkorb
genannt Klima und
transformationsfond seit heute ist er um
60 Milliarden Euro
Lehrer denn sie haben der Ampel die
Finanzplanung vermi der Zweite Senat des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts sorgt für ein
politisches Beben der Zweite Senat hat
wie sie eben gehört haben das zweite
nachtragshaushaltsgesetz
2021 insbesondere wegen Verstoßes gegen
die Ausnahmeregelung zur sogenannten
Schuldenbremse fürnichtig erklärt die
Ausnahmeregelung zur Schuldenbremse
rechtfertigte
2021 zusatzkredite des Bundes zunächst
in Höhe von 180 dann weiteren 60
Milliarden Euro diese Aufstockung blieb
ungenutzt die Ampel steckte sie
nachträglich in das Sondervermögen für
Energiewende und Klimaschutz Projekte 60
zusätzliche Milliarden unter anderem für
e-autoprämien und die Förderung
energetischer Gebäudesanierung dass es
so wie von der Ampel konstruiert nicht
geht haben Experten
vorausgesagt wenn die Verfassung ganz
klar sagt es geht um notlagenbewältigung
da muss zwischen Kreditaufnahme und
Notlage zwischen einer aktuellen
Situation ein Zusammenhang bestehen aber
für aktuelle Probleme die auch
Dauerprobleme sind muss Politik einfach
anders Finanzmittel erwirtschaften die
100 Milliarden Bundeswehr Sondervermögen
sind vom heutigen Urteil nicht betroffen
dieser Topf ist durch eine extaklausel
im Grundgesetz abgesichert
Schattenhaushalte gibt es viele sowohl
im Bund als auch in den Ländern für alle
ist jetzt klar es gelten strenge
Maßstäbe ich sage auch ausdrücklich
danke dem Bundesverfassungsgericht dass
es die Schuldenbremse des Grundgesetzes
bestätigt hat und mit sehr klaren und
scharfen Konturen ausgestattet hat es
ist das erste Urteil des des
Verfassungsgerichts zur Schuldenbremse
eines das deutlich gemacht hat
Haushaltsdisziplin ist keine politische
Option sondern
Verfassungsgebot ganz praktisch bedeutet
diese Botschaft aus Karlsruhe ein Korb
voller Geld ist künftig nicht mehr so
leicht zu
bestücken ja das ist eine gewaltige
Herausforderung für die Regierung was
man auch daran sehen kann dass sie sich
heute zunächst mal sammeln wollte und
erer nicht zum Fragen beantworten ins
Fernsehen
klar ist die Reaktion der CDU CSU
Opposition sie spricht von einer
politischen Katastrophe und einem
neuwahlmoment Daniel
ponzen seinen Humor hatte der Kanzler
nicht verloren seine Angewohnheit Dinge
sehr manchmal sehr sehr positiv
darzustellen ließ er sich auch durch das
heutige Urteil nicht nehmen auch wenn er
über seine Schlussfolgerung selbst
schmunzeln musste für uns ist ganz klar
dass das jetzt eine Sache ist die wir
auch gerne mit dem Parlament erörtern
und deshalb freue ich mich dass N genau
heute die Befragung des Kanzlers im
Bundestag gleich beginnt die war
kalendarischer Zufall für just danach
terminiert doch bevor es rüberging ins
Plenum ließ sich an den Statements der
beiden Minister schon andeutungsweise
erkennen dass es mit der Freude in der
Ampel bei diesem Thema schon bald vorbei
sein könnte ich habe heute nach
Paragraph 41 der
bundeshaushaltsordnung eine Sperre des
wirch splans des Klima und
transformationsfonds vorgenommen
ausgenommen sind Maßnahmen zur Förderung
der Energieeffizienz und der
erneuerbaren Energien im Gebäudebereich
die Beschlüsse des Gerichts heute und
die Umsetzung durch den
Bundesfinanzminister bedeuten dass alle
zugesagten Verpflichtungen eingehalten
werden und neue Verpflichtungen erst
eingegangen werden können wenn der neue
Wirtschaftsplan aufgestellt wird ich
hoffe dass die Arbeit daran zeitnah
beginnt und beendet wird daneben den von
Lindner erwähnten Maßnahmen auch weitere
Förderungen aus dem V finanziert werden
sollen der E-Mobilität etwa
Eisenbahninfrastruktur
Halbleiterproduktion oder
wasserstoffindustrie stellt sich schon
bald die Frage der Finanzierung wenn 60
Milliarden weniger da sind als die knapp
100 Milliarden bisher
eingeplanten jetzt gehen wir zum
Bundestag dort wartete bereits die Union
die ja geklagt hatte in Karlsruhe und
bei denen manche heute selbst ein wenig
überrascht waren wie umfassend das
Gericht ihrer Argumentation gefolgt war
die von ihm ausgerufene Zeitenwende
beginne damit heute unwiderruflich so
die Union Richtung Ampel sie werden von
uns keine Zustimmung bekommen wenn sie
denn ernsthafterweise jetzt vorschlagen
sollten die Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes zu lockern die
Bundesregierung muss jetzt das erste Mal
in ihrer Amtszeit etwas tun was sie bis
jetzt sorgfältig vermieden hat sie muss
mit dem Geld auskommen das im
Bundeshaushalt der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland vereinnahmt wird zudem gab
ist die Aufforderung die für morgen
angesetzte
haushaltsbereinigungssitzung zu
verschieben dass das nicht seriös
funktionieren kann ist doch ganz
offensichtlich man muss ja nicht nur für
den Haushalt 24 sondern auch für die
mittelfristige Finanzplanung sorgen und
dafür Klarheit schaffen wo werden diese
60 Milliarden eben nicht eingesetzt
werden können Hinweise auf solche
Sparideen gab es aus der Ampel in
besagter regierungsbefragung erst einmal
kaum stattdessen die Frage der Grünen an
den
er an den geplanten klimaschutzinvestien
festhalten WLE das wird jetzt genau zu
prüfen sein wie wir den
zukunftsherausforderung weiter begegnen
können und ich bin überzeugt davon dass
es der Regierungskoalition sehr
einvernehmlich gelingen wird dort die
richtigen Vorschläge zu machen sie dann
auch im Deutschen Bundestag zu
beschließen sehr einvernehmlich so der
Kanzler ob diese Prognose vor allem
humorvoll realistisch oder optimistisch
ist werden die nächsten Wochen
zeigen der Erfinder der Schuldenbremse
ist Lars Feld Professor für
Wirtschaftspolitik an der Uni in
Freiburg Herr Professor guten
Abend guten Abend her Sivers ja fangen
wir vielleicht mal an mit dem
handwerklichen Aspekt des ganzen das ist
ja ein offenbarungsalt für den
Finanzminister dessen Berater sie jetzt
sind ein verheerendes Zeugnis aus
Karlsruhe für die deutsche Finanzpolitik
wie peinlich ist
das
ach ich denke nicht in Kategorien von
Peinlichkeit es ist einfach so
dass ähm die Auffassung in der
Bundesregierung insbesondere noch beim
Vorgänger des jetzigen Finanzministers
Diva dass es gelingen würde mit einer
solchen Transaktion
ähm verfassungsgemäß Haushalte
aufzustellen das hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht nun klar
verneint jetzt sagt die FDP heute das
sei eine Stärkung für die Schuldenbremse
da muss man allerdings dazu sagen eine
Stärkung für die Schuldenbremse die die
FDP ja mit selbst geschwächt hat laut
Gericht das heißt doch zunächst mal dass
die Finanzpolitik die Haushaltspolitik
in Deutschland aktuell nicht seriös ist
oder soweit würde ich nicht gehen dass
es nicht seriöses man muss bei diesen
Diskussionen um Sondervermögen immer
auch die Funktion von solchen
Institutionen sehen es geht ja bei
Sondervermögen auch darum intertemporal
äh für bestimmte Zwecke Mittel zur
Verfügung zu stellen denken Sie
beispielsweise an das Sondervermögen für
die Flutopfer aus demal wir haben
vielfältige äh Sondervermögen dieser Art
ja Sondervermögen schon das Wort ist ja
eigentlich ein Problem wenn man es mal
genau nimmt das handelt sich ja um
sonderschulden und die
Verfassungsrichter haben heute gesagt
damit muss man ganz ganz ganz gezielt
und sehr sehr vorsichtig und
zurückhaltend umgehen deswegen gucken
wir doch jetzt mal ein bisschen in die
Zukunft Herr Professor der
Finanzminister muss ja jetzt liefern
wenn die Schuldenbremse bleiben soll wie
wir heute gehört haben FDP will das ja
CDU CSU wollen daran auch nicht rütteln
wenn diese Buch Tricks die wir da jetzt
gesehen haben laut Verfassungsgericht
verfassungswidrig sind wenn es keine
Steuererhöhungen gibt und geben soll was
bleibt denn dann
noch dann muss man auf der Ausgabenseite
Prioritäten setzen man muss ganz klar
sagen was will man als erstes
realisieren und was muss zurückstehen
und dann wird man schon feststellen dass
in den 10 Jahren seit 2010 in der
günstigen wachstumssituation in der wir
uns bis 2019 befunden haben doch sehr
sehr viele haushaltsspielräume bestanden
haben und deswegen auch vieles
durchgeführt werden konnte was nice to
have war was man aber heute auch
vielleicht noch einmal hinterfragen muss
haben sie da ein Beispiel was war nice
to have und was könnte man jetzt äh ja
drauf
verzichten nun wir haben ja ein paar
Punkte schon im Hinblick auf den
Bundeshaushalt 2024 diskutiert ein
Beispiel ist das Elterngeld gewesen äh
wir haben auf der Steuer Seite
Steuervergünstigungen also noch nicht
einmal zu Zeiten äh der
guten Finanzlage sondern erst mit der
coronasituation gibt es einen ermäßigen
Umsatzsteuersatz für das Gastgewerbe
auch der ist in der Diskussion und so
werden sich immer wieder eine ganze
Reihe von Maßnahmen finden mit denen man
eine Gegenfinanzierung vornehmen kann
und was ist mit den Maßnahmen deren
Finanzierung jetzt aktuell hochgradig
gefährdet und unklar ist also sprich was
heißt das für Wirtschaft was heißt das
für die Bürger die sie sich eingestellt
haben auf Hilfe des Staates bei
Klimaschutz Vorhaben bei dieser großen
Transformation die unserem Land
bevorsteht ich denke dass man im
Hinblick auf die Transformation und den
Klimaschutz noch einmal hinterfragen
muss ob es tatsächlich Sinn macht
einerseits mit Ordnungsrecht und
andererseits mit so umfassenden
subventionsmaßnahmen als leitinstrumente
zu arbeiten im Grunde wird es den
Klimaschutz weltweit nur geben wenn wir
eine ordentliche Bepreisung von CO2
haben und das zumindest mit einem
Mindestpreis international abgesichert
haben also mit einer internationalen
Vereinbarung die auch echt bindend ist
ansonsten werden wir nicht weiterkommen
also einfach nur zu subventionieren und
umzustellen der Wirtschaft ganz viel
Geld zu geben dafür das ist nicht
zielführend und meines Erachtens bietet
das Urteil gerade auch die Möglichkeit
die Klimapolitik vom Kopf auf die Beine
zu stellen da muss natürlich dann eine
Ampelkoalition in all ihren Teilen
mitziehen wir erleben aber ja ein
fundamental unterschiedliches Verhältnis
zum zum Geld kann man sagen und zur
Rolle des Staates dass ich bislang mit
viel Geld kaschieren ließ aber jetzt
voll aufbricht wie lang kann das aus
ihrer Sicht politisch noch gut
gehen n das hängt immer auch davon ab
wie kompromissfähig die Partner sind und
die Situation ist ja nun für fast alle
Parteien im Deutschen Bundestag bis auf
die AFD die dass keiner an Neuwahlen
interessiert sein kann und vor dem
Hintergrund ist die Notwendigkeit da
sich zusammenzuraufen und wenn etwas
notwendig ist dann wird es am Ende auch
gelingen
die Kompromisse zu erzielen sagt
Professor Lars Feld einer der Erfinder
der Schuldenbremse Professor vielen Dank
guten Abend nach Freiburg im breiskau
ich danke
ihnen vielen Dank Herr sias im heute
journal Update Fragen an den CDU CSU
fraktionsfze Matthias Middelberg dessen
Fraktion ja beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht geklagt hatte
und so viiel zunächst zu diesem Thema
freue mir so ein bisschen Blätter weg
und komme zum nächsten Thema heute Abend
der Einsatz geht so lange weiter wie
nötig sagt Israels Armeesprecher heute
Abend über die Lage im
schifaherkrankenhaus dem größten
Hospital von Gaza in dem verheerende
Zustände herrschen die Armee hatte das
Krankenhaus vergangene Nacht gestürmt
Israel sagt unter dem Krankenhaus sei
ein operatives Hauptquartier der Hamas
entdeckt worden ein Reporter der
Nachrichtenagentur AFP berichtet von
Soldaten die von Raum zu Raum gingen auf
den Stationen und dabei immer wieder
Warnschüsse abgaben sie hätten auch
Frauen
durchsucht nun ist die die Stürmung
eines Krankenhauses auch im Krieg so
ziemlich das letzte was man von der
Armee eines demokratischen Staates
erwarten würde dementsprechend heftig
sind die internationalen Reaktionen
dementsprechend wichtig ist der Armee
die Darstellung es habe sich um einen
präzisen und gezielten Einsatz gegen
Hamas gehandelt Stefan Schlösser
berichtet aus Tel
Aviv die israelische Armee weiß genau
was sie liefern muss handfeste
Beweise wir machen ein Video mit einer
Einstellung keine
Schnitte sagte Armeesprecher der
offenkundig vor einem Eingang des
schieferkrankenhauses steht dann folgt
ihm die Kamera ins Gebäude fast 7
Minuten lang wir kürzen das Video für
die
Berichterstattung in einem Raum mit
einem MRT hätten sie eine Tasche mit der
Ausrüstung eines Terror
hier haben wir eine AK47 da sind
Magazine da sind Granaten
drin die Überwachungskameras wurden alle
unbrauchbar gemacht weitere Waffen
finden sich in den
Schränken das alles soll die
Öffentlichkeit und vor allem die
Kritiker überzeugen dass die Hamas sich
in zivilen Einrichtungen
versteckt zusätzlich haben wir eine
Kommandozentrale gefunden ausgestattet
mit Kommunikation
h gehen die fortwährenden Kämpfe der
letzten Tage haben schwere Spuren auch
im Inneren des alchiver Krankenhauses
hinterlassen und den Betrieb fast
unmöglich gemacht in der vergangenen
Nacht dringen dann die israelischen
Truppen in das Gebäude ein Bilder davon
gibt es bisher nicht telefonisch
beschreibt ein Arzt diesen
Moment alle waren wirklich verängstigt
die Situation war wirklich schwierig sie
haben die Krankenhausverwaltung anger
und gesagt dass sie in ein Gebäude nach
dem anderen reingehen und alles im
Krankenhaus überprüfen werden sie haben
uns also vorer
informiert ob ein tunnelkomplex gefunden
wurde ist bisher nicht bekannt Israel
wirf der Hamas vor unter und in der Nähe
des Krankenhauses eine weit verzweigte
Kommandozentrale eingerichtet zu haben
eine Animation der israelischen Armee
soll das Ausmaß der Tunnelanlagen zeigen
beim Betreten der Klinik kam es offenbar
zu einem Schusswechsel mit mehreren
hamaserroristen die getötet worden sein
im Gebäude selbst habe es keine direkten
Kämpfe gegeben so der Armeesprecher
bereits am
Morgen zu den Einsatzkräften gehören
auch ärzteeteams und Arabisch Übersetzer
die ein spezielles Training absolviert
haben um für diesen sensiblen Einsatz
vorbereitet zu sein mit der Absicht dass
den Zivilisten die von der Hamas als
Schutzschilde genutzt werden kein
Schaden zugefügt
wird die Soldaten dur weiter das
Krankenhaus die bis jetzt präsentierten
Funde sollen erst der Anfang gewesen
sein zu den internationalen Reaktionen
gehört auch eine die jetzt gerade ganz
aktuell hereinkommt aus New York danach
hat der UNO Sicherheitsrat eine Zitat
ausgedehnte humanitäre Pause nein sogar
im Plural ausgedehnte humanitäre Pausen
das ist ja sehr wichtig in diesen Tagen
für den Gazastreifen gefordert diese
Resolution hat das mächtigste Gremium
der Vereinten Nation en passiert und
zwar gab es keine Gegenstimme drei
Enthaltungen und unter diesen drei
Enthaltungen das ist interessant auch
die USA die sich als enger Verbündeter
Israels also nicht dagegen gestellt
hatten sondern sich nur
entthielten so nach dieser ganz
aktuellen Nachricht jetzt ein Überblick
über das was heute auch wichtig ist von
dir gunduller Bundeskanzler Scholz hat
sich bei der Befragung im Bundestag auch
zum Thema irreguläre Migration geäußert
er rechne damit dass die im Oktober
eingeführten Kontrollen an Deutschlands
Grenzen zu Polen Tschechien und der
Schweiz noch sehr lange fortgesetzt
werden auch geht Scholz davon aus dass
die beschlossene Einführung einer
Bezahlkarte für Asylbewerber bald in die
Tat umgesetzt werde so sollen
Überweisungen in die Herkunftsländer
verhindert werden binnen weniger Stunden
sind erneut mehr als 1300
Bootsflüchtlinge auf der italienischen
Mittelmeer Insel Lampedusa gelandet nach
Behördenangaben stammen die Migranten
aus Syrien Ägypten Pakistan und
Bangladesch insgesamt kamen seit
Jahresbeginn mindestens
146 000 Menschen ohne Papiere über den
gefährlichen Seeweg nach Italien 60.000
mehr als im
Vorjahreszeitraum der Oberste
Gerichtshof in Großbritannien hat den
asylpakt der Regierung mit Ruanda für
rechtswidrig erklärt das ostafrikanische
Ruanda sei kein sicheres Drittland
dorthingebrachte geflüchtete erhielten
möglicherweise keine fairen
Asylverfahren jährlich kommen 10tausende
Migranten über den ermelkanal nach
Großbritannien die konservative
Regierung hat an Ruanda bereits
umgerechnet 160 Millionen Euro gezahlt
auch für den Bau von
Aufnahmezentren in Deutschland wird der
gesetzliche mindestl in zwei Schritten
um 82 Cent steigen bis Januar
2025 auf
12,82 das Bundeskabinett hat die
entsprechende Verordnung von
Arbeitsminister Heil gebilligt und damit
einen Anstieg von
6,8%. Gewerkschaftsvertreter hatten eine
deutlich stärkere Erhöhung gefordert
wegen Schüssen auf spezialkräfte der
Polizei ist ein sogenannter Reichsbürger
zu einer hohen Haftstrafe verurteil
14halb Jahre soll der 55-Jährige ins
Gefängnis wegen mehrfachen versuchten
Mordes so das Oberlandesgericht
Stuttgart bei einer rtiia in seinem
Wohnhaus im badenwürtembergischen
Boxberg hatte der Angeklagte auf die
Beamten geschossen und einen schwer
verletzt noch ist das Urteil nicht
rechtskräftig der Verteidiger kündigte
Revision
an eine Notrufnummer zur handhen alle
Fälle das ist immer ratsam umso mehr
wenn es sich um zwei Atommächte handelt
die in letzter Zeit erhebliche
Unstimmigkeiten und Probleme miteinander
hatten mal wieder einen Kontakt finden
so hat US-Präsident Joe Biden das
Minimalziel umschrieben für sein Treffen
mit dem Amtskollegen hijin Ping aus
China der kam von Westen nach San
Francisco beiden aus dem Osten und dort
in San Francisco wartet die
asienpazifikk Konferenz und es wartet
eine Welt auch und gerade eine
international vernetzte Wirtschaftswelt
gespannt auf jedes Wort und jedes
Zeichen von Annäherung oder Streit
Benjamin daniel hat
Details China kommt Amerika salutiert
die Gegenpole könnten kaum stärker
aufgeladen sein und doch hoffieren sich
die Weltmächte heute gegenseitig
Austausch von Freundlichkeiten auf ganz
großer Bühne der Grund ein gemeinsames
Ziel im Interesse beider
Seiten wir müssen wieder normal
miteinander reden dass wir einfach das
Telefon in die Hand nehmen und über
Krisen sprechen können außerdem sollten
sich unsere Militärs wieder
austauschen wichtig um Missverständnisse
und unnötige Eskalation zu vermeiden der
direkte kommunikationsdraht zwischen den
Streitkräften ist gekappt seit die
damalige Sprecherin des US
Repräsentantenhauses Nancy Pelosi vor
gut einem Jahr überraschend Taiwan
besuchte die demokratische Inselrepublik
einer der größten Streitpunkte den die
Präsidenten zur Stunde wohl besprechen
für den Fall einer chinesischen Invasion
hatte beiden Taiwan militärische
Unterstützung zugesagt Shi verbittet
sich jede
Einmischung die Wiedervereinigung mit
taiwan ist für die chinesische Führung
extrem wichtig geworden shijing PIN
unterstreicht das ja auch regelmäßig das
heißt aber nicht dass ein militärischer
Konflikt unvermeidbar ist ich werde mir
die Ergebnisse der im Januar anstehenden
Wahlen in Taiwan genau ansehen sie
könnten beeinflussen wie sich die
Situation weiter entwickeln
wird ein weiterer Konfliktpunkt Chinas
weitreichende Gebietsansprüche im
Indopazifik die zunehmende US
Militärpräsenz ist Shi ein Dorn im Auge
hinzu kommen unterschiedliche Haltungen
zum Krieg zwischen Israel und der Hamas
dem russischen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine und zu zahlreichem anderem aber
wer weiß vielleicht gelingt den beiden
mächtigen Männern ja doch die
Wiederentdeckung des konstruktiven
beiden hofft auf Unterstützung beim
Kampf gegen die drogenepidemie China
hingegen auf geringere Importzölle und
mehr
Investitionen wir versuchen nicht uns
von China abzukoppeln wir versuchen
unsere Beziehung zu ändern und zwar zum
besseren im Reich der Mitte besagt ein
Sprichwort dass man das Leben der
lächelnd meistert oder gar nicht wie
viel böses Blut heute von guten Minen
überdeckt wird und ob echtes
annäherungsinteresse oder vor allem
wirtschaftliches Kalkül hinter der
diplomatischen Geschmeidigkeit steht
nicht nur Amerika und China sind
gespannt auf die
Antwort nach Deutschland zynisch
betrachtet hat der Bahnstreik dann doch
einen Vorteil für die Fahrgäste sie
müssen nicht mehr Rätseln wann denn nun
der Zug kommt die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass er gar nicht kommt ist extrem hoch
die lockführergewerkschaft GDL streigt
seit knapp 9 Minuten bis morgen Abend
und damit eskaliert der Tarifstreit
zwischen Bahn und Gewerkschaft bereits
kurz nach der ersten Verhandlungsrunde
Petra Neubauer ist für uns am
Hauptbahnhof in München guten Abend
Petra wie zeigt sich denn die Situation
aktuell auf Deutschlands
Schienen na ja hinter mir sieht man es
die Bahnsteige sind hier teilweise schon
leer die Bahn hat aber auch den ganzen
Tag über schon erste Verbindungen
gestrichen einfach um zu verhindern dass
die Züge dann mit streigbeginn irgendwo
stranden insgesamt rechnet die Bahn dass
bei diesem 20stündigen Ausstand rund 80%
aller Fernverbindungen gestrichen werden
und es werden auch große massive
Beeinträchtigungen beim Regionalverkehr
erwartet und auch in Städten wie München
oder Nürnberg bei den S-Bahnen denn auch
die gehören zur Deutschen Bahn die
Deutsche Bahn hat Notfallpläne
erarbeitet hat eine streikhotline
eingerichtet und will auch bei den
Tickets recht großzügig sein die Tickets
gelten länger es gibt keine Zugbindung
was die Stimmung bei den Reisenden
angeht mit denen wir hier gesprochen
haben da gibt es so eine Zweiteilung es
gibt welche die haben durchaus
Verständnis für diese Maßnahmen es gibt
aber auch schon ja erste die ihren Unmut
äußern die hat's kalt erwischt und es
ist auch alles recht kurzfris gewesen ja
man kann sich vorstellen wie das dann
morgen früh im Berufsverkehr sein wird
jetzt ist das ja Petra einigermaßen
ungewöhnlich dass so früh in der
Tarifrunde bereits gestreikt wird die
Bahn hat jetzt wiederum alle weiteren
Verhandlungstermine erstmal für diese
Woche abgesagt wie soll es denn da
weitergehen ja die Bahn hat gesagt
entweder verhandeln oder streiken und
hat deshalb alles abgesagt die GDL ist
da anderer Meinung und hat angekündigt
demonstrativ morgen am Verhandlungsort
zu erscheinen nur allein verhandeln das
macht natürlich keinen Sinn Knackpunkt
bei diesem Tarifkonflikt ist die von der
GDL geforderte Verkürzung der
Arbeitszeit auf 35 Stunden pro Woche bei
vollem Lohnausgleich sagt die Bahn das
ist völlig unmöglich undenkbar die GDL
aber sagt man muss zumindestens mal
drüber reden und eine von den beiden
Seiten oder beide Seiten müssen sich
jetzt bewegen weil ansonsten könnte das
hier ein sehr langfristiger und sehr
zäher Tarifkonflikt werden Petra
Neubauer live vom Hauptbahnhof in
München Petra vielen
Dank wir bleiben bei der Wirtschaft mit
dir Gundula ja Thema an der Börse war
wieder Siemens Energy der krieselnde
energietechnikkonzern nach der
milliardenbürgschaft des Bundes gestern
kam heute die Meldung eines Milliarden
schweren rekordverlustes Frank betmann
wie ist das junge Unternehmen nun
insgesamt finanziell aufgestellt na ja
man ist nicht auf Rosen gebettet dank
der Staatsgarantien aber geht es weiter
denn es ist das in der spanischen
Einheit Siemens gamäer gebündelte
windkraftgeschäft welches Siemens Energy
ja bereits seit Jahren die Bilanz
verhagelt gebe es das Geschäft mit den
Windturbinen nicht würde der Konzern mit
seiner Gaskraft Sparte und den
Stromnetzen Gewinne schreiben so aber
setzte es mit rund 4,6 Milliarden Euro
den größten Verlust in der
Unternehmensgeschichte und das bei einer
sehr guten Auftragslage auftrage
Aufträge im Umfang von von 112
Milliarden Euro hat man aktuell in der
Pipeline das Problem aber im Anlagenbau
ist dass die Kunden einen Teilbetrag
vorab bezahlen müssen bevor Siemens
Energy also überhaupt loslegt dafür
braucht es Garantien üblicherweise von
Banken die waren nach den hohen
Verlusten dazu aber nicht mehr bereit
erst als der Bund gesagt hat wir bürgen
größtenteils dafür war die Kuh vom Eis
ja und warum kann die Windkraftindustrie
trotz hoher Nachfrage keine Gewinne
erwirtschaften ja das ist die
Gretchenfrage Windkraft das ist
Energiewende das ist Zukunft aber eben
auch knallharter Preiskampf keiner
verdient derzeit richtig Geld damit
hinzu kommen massive hausgemachte
Probleme schadhafte Rotorblätter oder
schlechte Getriebelager da sind also
auch intern Fehler gemacht worden Frank
betmann vielen Dank und wir haben jetzt
die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch
sie lauten 8 13 14 22 25 2 Superzahl 1
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de
und im ZDF Text eine Personalie aus der
Fußballbundesliga der Tabellenletzte
Union Berlin hat sich von Trainer Urs
Fischer getrennt bis auf weiteres soll
unions U19 Trainer Marco grote die
Mannschaft betreuen Konsequenz aus 14
Spielen ohne Sieg die Trennung wurde
einvernehmlich beschlossen so der Club
Fischer hatte die Berliner in seiner
fünfjährigen Amtszeit erfolgreich von
der zweiten Bundesliga bis in die
Champions League
geführt das auslandsjournal guckt gleich
auf die Rolle der USA im Nahostkonflikt
Weltpolizist wieder Willen wie der
Gazakrieg Amerika in ein Dilemma stürzt
das wird sehr sehenswert gleich nach uns
hier im ZDF und gegen 0:30 Uhr meldet
sich nasan göckdem mit unserem heute
journal Update von uns allen hier Ihnen
allen einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Konzentration
an Treibhausgasen in der Atmosphäre hat
Rekordhöhe erreicht das berichtet die
weltmeteorologieorganisation WMO
treibausgase wie Kohlendioxid Methan und
Gas halten die Wärme auf unserem
Planeten das ermöglicht leben aber zu
viel davon lässt die Temperaturen immer
weiter steigen schauen wir auf die
einzelnen Gase kohlendioxid ist
langlebig und das häufigste Klimagas im
Vergleich zur vorindustriellen Zeit ist
die Konzentration um 50% gestiegen
verursacht durch den Menschen Methan
kurzlebiger aber um ein Vielfaches
wirksamer als CO2 hat sich deutlich mehr
als verdoppelt noch wirk ist Lachgas und
auch hier steigt die Konzentration
weiter an und zu viel Wärme bedeutet
auch extremes Wetter das Wetter wird
dadurch aufgeladen wir schauen erstmal
in die Nacht da haben wir im Nordosten
Regen der abzieht und das bei
Temperaturen tiefsten Werten von 0 bis
7°. ja und morgen gibt es im Nordosten
noch etwas Regen zieht ab dazwischen
lockerts auf im Südwesten kommt Regen
auf und dann zum Abend hin von Südwesten
her ein heftiger Sturm in den tiefen
Lagen sturmböhnen in den hohen Lagen
orkanböhnen und das bei Temperaturen von
5 bis 12°. die nächsten Tage am Freitag
zieht der Sturm ab bei 3 bis 9° und am
Samstag ist es relativ trocken ein
schöner Abend